rainer wendt will ich noch mal ganz
herzlich grüßen der mit uns diese live
bilder jetzt gerade verfolgt wie
schwierig ist die situation für die
beamten und lassen sie uns genau auch
bei dieser konkreten situation bleiben
das ist alles verbarrikadiert selbst die
räume panzer kommen da nicht durch es
ist dicht auch vermüllt mit metall mit
holz und jetzt ist man in der situation
man geht dort rein in eine völlig
ungewisse situation
man weiß nur die andere seite die es
gewaltbereite
herausforderungen nicht nur diese
räumungsaktion man hat das gesamte
umfeld das heißt die polizei ist auf
vielen nebenschauplätzen unterwegs sie
muss die objekte schützen die attackiert
werden möglicherweise das sind
pressehäuser das sind
andere öffentliche einrichtungen die
geschützt werden müssen und die
versammlungs lage die gibt es ja
nebenbei auch noch das heißt die polizei
hat auch die pflicht die das
versammlungsrecht durchzusetzen das
heißt versammlungen auch zu ermöglichen
das heißt man darf ja gegen diese
maßnahmen protestieren ist also
ausgesprochen schwierig und was diese
konkrete situation angeht die man ja
juristisch auch ein sortieren muss die
polizei leistet amtshilfe für die
gerichtsvollzieherin und sie hat mit dem
einsatzwagen da ein loch sehr vorsichtig
reingemacht manche haben wir die
erwartet die polizei soll mit diesem
schweren gerät das sie hier hat nur noch
einfach da mal rein fahren und großes
loch machen nein sie könnte
beispielsweise angriff personen die sich
hinter diesen barrikaden verbergen
verletzten und das darf nicht passieren
das heißt das hat man unbedingt
verhindern wollen und wir sehen jetzt
genau diesen einsatz von eben schwerem
gerät von diesen schweren fahrzeugen der
polizei hier vielleicht können sie
einmal ganz kurz beschreiben event mit
ihrer polizeilichen erfahrungen was
aktuell gemacht wird also wie habe
gerade gesehen dass mehrere bewohner
eben abgeführt worden und jetzt trinkt
man offenbar eben mit diesen fahrzeugen
tiefer auf das gelände jetzt kann man
das auch gefahrlos tun wenn man weiß was
sich dahinter unbedingt was sich
unmittelbar dahinter verbirgt so dass
der einsatz dieses gerätes den wir ja
aus anderen einsätzen schon kennen
möglich ist wie überhaupt die nicht nur
die berliner polizei sondern auch die
bundespolizei und andere einheiten die
hier im einsatz sind solche
einsatzsituationen seit langer langer
zeit kennen also auch dass menschen
beispielsweise sich an ketten oder
irgendwie die arme in betonröhren
stecken das kennen wir seit den castor
transporten und seitdem weiß polizei
auch mit solchen situationen umzugehen
es gibt höhen ritter die die leute von
den bäumen holen das kennt man aus dem
hambacher forst es wird ein sehr sehr
langer einsatz heute werden also man
darf sich von diesen bildern dass sich
da einige ganz ruhig abführen lassen
sich beeindrucken lassen das ist
durchaus auch ein teil der szenerie
dieser leute die dokumentieren wollen
wir sind ja eigentlich ganz friedlich
und böse ist nur die polizei das ist ein
altes szenario das immer wieder eine
halte ein narrativ das auch immer wieder
diese szene begleitet das ist eben auch
sehr besondere auch nochmal an diesem
heutigen tag dass die polizei ja auch
ganz klares feindbild ist das ist ganz
klar wir haben die rufe gehört werden
gehört wie flaschen auf die beamten
gerufen wie sie beschimpft werden wie
gewalt angekündigt wird wie rüstet sich
die polizei abgesehen von der
gerätschaft die wir hier sehen abgesehen
von der mannschaft von der unterstützung
die angefordert ist wie rissen sich die
polizei auch mental auf einen so langen
tag in dem man immer wieder persönlich
auch beschimpft wird immer jeder
einzelne beamte muss fürchten persönlich
angegangen wird hier kann man sich damit
heilkraft verbreiten das ist eine
wichtige aufgabe für die führungskräfte
der polizei für die zugführer für die
hundertschaftsführer die in den einsatz
vorbereitungen mit den einsatzkräften ja
sprechen das ist auch eine frage der
übermittlung von einsatzbefehle in der
den klar gemacht werden wie die polizei
und warum sie so einschreitet und da
müssen kolleginnen und kollegen schon
eingestellt werden auf diese
einsatzsituation vor allen dingen die
die direkt am objekt sind wissen
natürlich dass sie in lebensgefahr sind
wenn sie dort eingesetzt werden denn
diejenigen die sich dort zur wehr setzen
von denen geht ja gelegentlich eine hohe
tötungsbereitschaft aus das haben wir in
anderen objekten auch gesehen das heißt
sie müssen so entschlossen wie sie
vorgehen müssen müssen sie auch behutsam
vorgehen und auf ihre eigene sicherheit
machen nun ist es ja geradezu
spektakulär und macht einen auch wütend
wie massiv dieser einsatz durchgeführt
werden muss wie viele polizeikräfte aus
dem ganzen bundesgebiet heute
eingezogen werden müssen um diese
räumung durchzusetzen wir haben der
höhenretter zusätzlich gesehen also das
ist ein gigantischer einsatz heute der
verschiedenen polizeien haben sie eine
ungefähre größenordnung was das kostet
was das für eine rechnung ist na ja das
kann man immer sehr schlecht berechnen
weil die polizistinnen und polizisten
die wir im einsatz sind beamte sind und
die werden sozusagen sowieso bezahlt ob
sie an dieser stelle oder an anderer
stelle im einsatz sind insofern ist das
für die polizei kann
kostenmanagement was der was da ins feld
geführt werden kann aber für uns ist
wichtig mal festzuhalten sie hat sich
über 30 jahre lang eine szene verfestigt
geduldet von der politik und dass die
natürlich sich in 30 jahren auf eine
solche situation vorbereiten können ist
völlig klar und diese 30 jahre sind
einfach 30 jahre zu viel man darf
besetzte gebäude eben nicht dulden nicht
ein jahr nicht zehn jahre und schon
garnicht 30 dann entstehen erst solche
situationen geduldet von der politik
dass ein ganz interessanter punkt
benennen sie uns mal ganz klar die
fehler wer hat er den fehler gemacht wo
wurde geschlafen das ist eine situation
vor der wir jetzt heute stehen 2000
ihrer kolleginnen und kollegen sind im
einsatz wer ist es der rot rot oder rot
rot rote senat wer hat da geschlafen es
sich die szene doch hier in der
hauptstadt so stark machen konnte er
glücklicherweise werden wir ja nicht
seit 30 jahren von rot rot grün regiert
aber von unterschiedlichen koalition
aber eins ist immer durchgängig gewesen
dass es in der politik in weiten teilen
der linken politik bei den grünen bei
der linkspartei aber auch an tagen der
spd eine breite sympathie für diese
szene gibt die völlig unverhohlen
geäußert wird wodurch man natürlich sich
auch legitimiert wird führt so zu
agieren und so fort zu gehen
glücklicherweise ist es so dass polizei
und justiz also die gerichtsvollzieherin
ganz ruhig und entschlossen recht und
gesetz durchsetzen und nicht an
parteipolitische erwartungshaltung
gebunden sind ich kann nur hoffen dass
das noch lange so bleibt und dass die
polizei nicht geführt wird sozusagen von
linken und grünen politikern sondern von
recht und gesetz das ist der rechtsstaat
alles andere wäre chaos sie haben groll
mit in dieses studio heute gebracht bei
bleibt das merkt man natürlich nachdem
das über so viele die jahrzehnte
geduldet wurde wie sehr spüren sie
diesen groll auch unter den beamten die
im einsatz sind die das heute natürlich
hoch professionell machen und ganz ganz
sachlich und deeskalierend aber
inwieweit merken sie diesen groll in
reihen der polizei grundsätzlich prüfen
und den schon bei den kolleginnen und
kollegen wenn man mit ihnen spricht bei
diesem einsatz pflicht denn heute morgen
da auch vor ort gewesen habe schon
gesehen wieder einige von schwarz
vermummten aufmarschiert sind haben mit
vielen einsatzkräften gesprochen die
sind gelassen und wirklich professionell
sie wissen ganz genau sie haben
gefährlichen auftrag aber sie haben
einen gesetzlichen auftrag und fühlen
sich auch sicher auf der seite von recht
und gesetz das was sie machen ist
rechtsstaat durchsetzen und deshalb
haben sie ein gutes gefühl dabei auch
wenn sie hoch wachsam sind völlig klar
aber eben auch mit der notwendigen
professionellen gelassenheit sie haben
eine gute schutzausstattung sie haben
gutes gerät sie haben auch erfahrene
führungskräfte diese szene kennen die
sich auch gut vorbereitet haben von
daher im einsatz gibt es keinen groll da
gibt es professionalität das ist genau
richtig und da gibt es ruhe und
entschlossene gelassenheit was ganz
deutschland können wir gerade noch mal
an den wappen am see niedersachsen nach
wir gerade gesehen berliner kollegen
oder sachsen haben wir gesehen hier
berliner kollegen die bundespolizei ist
im einsatz und aus etlichen anderen
ländern wird berlin immer unterstützt
bei solchen einsätzen das ist ja auch
selbstverständlich alle länder
unterstützen sich gegenseitig und die
bundespolizei natürlich auch und alle
länder haben auch unterschiedliche
erfahrungen wie beispielsweise höhen
rettungskräfte aus nordrhein westfalen
die kennen das aus dem hambacher forst
und die werden dann natürlich auch
angefordert und die können das auch aber
der einsatz da darf man sich keine
illusionen machen der wird noch lange
viele stunden heute dauern das heißt ich
denke mal dass bis in die abendstunden
hinein das dauern wird und selbst wenn
er dann vor ort erst mal beendet ist
werden die anschließenden
demonstrationen und auseinandersetzungen
uns noch lange beschäftigen man da ist
erleben wir ja hier in albstadt ich zum
ersten mal ihre prognose wie sehr wird
hier knallen heute nacht also
insbesondere nach dem einsatz wird sich
die ganze wut gegen die einsatzkräfte
entladen und da kann man sich durchaus
auch auf gewalttätige
auseinandersetzungen die geplante wut
muss man ja sagen das ist angekündigte
wut das inszenierte wo das sind menschen
die pilger in der heute hin was sind das
ihrer erfahrung nach für menschen die
das alles noch unterstützen also die
linksextremen das ja jetzt keine so
große gruppe dass die zu tausenden auf
die straße geht aber so haben wir es
beim letzten mal erlebt rund um liebe
ich 34 als dann ebenso massive
demonstrationen unterstützt von so
vielen auf den straßen am abend in der
nacht stattfinden also was sind das für
leute die dann dahin pilgern und ihren
kolleginnen und kollegen zusätzlich das
leben schwer ich würde mal sagen sind
eigentlich nicht viele es sind manchmal
die werden auch durch durch manche
kameraaufnahmen dann viel mehr zu viel
mehr gemacht hat sie in wahrheit sind ja
es sind immer einige hundert die
besonders gewaltbereit sind und die dann
auch diese massiven bilder wir
produzieren aber die gerade bei der
liebe straße hat man ja gesehen dass die
anwohnerinnen und anwohner völlig
genervt sind von dieser szene das
überhaupt nicht wollen das gilt mit
sicherheit auch für die anwohner dieser
szenerie die wollen da in ruhe und
frieden leben und nicht permanent von
diesen einsätzen behelligt werden und
wir wollen auch nicht permanent diese
szene vor augen haben die ist in
wahrheit gemessen an der berliner
bevölkerung sehr klein aber sehr
gewaltbereit und sehr lautstark und sehr
wirkmächtig man sieht ja dass parteien
wie die grünen und die linken ihnen
folgen und unverhohlen für sie aus
importiert
[Musik]